right down playing in the bullet zone 1
1 minute 18 seconds 24 players let's be
lucky number 25 now 26
somebody joined just before me ok 1
minute 6 here we go I don't have a good
feeling about this have a good one okay
here we go
38 37 36 it's a countdown game on 30
seconds 29 players look at these heavy
hitters what do we got 17:24 1924 forget
it
25 Collett the average rating is 21 27
which is very high 22 2015 2023 I feel a
lot of beatings coming on a lot of
beatings and I'm not gonna be the one
giving them out oh look at this kid I
gotta play against a little kid here
this is gonna be bad if I can't win this
one right okay I can't move your pieces
get these pieces out it's a little bit
it's sticking a little bit Bishop c4
let's chop that I don't want to waste
any time and maybe I could be getting a
mate on the diagonal here it's gonna
clean up are they gonna really take that
pun probably crazy if they do that I'm
looking for a 5v5 coming up let's do it
and get this in Bishop to d3 I think
mm-hmm to try that this could be strong
uh-oh uh-oh
f7 coming under fire see
six and f7 now night right here I take I
take with check first and then oh man oh
I'm in trouble
my Knights dead my Knights dead okay but
I'm looking for east six let's do this
first
what am I missing oh wait I just got a
clean I got a clean mate
Bishop c6 I just take it and backup no
that's not it I just play my bishop here
no it's a Meghan two or now I take here
first the bishop has to play back that's
a pretty smooth way to get to that
square and I'm gonna insist on it the
bishops gonna move now on my Knights
pinned I got to get out of that crap
okay check okay this has to be good rook
here there we go this is leading to me
the Queen Esther block and then I give
me okay out back to tournament
tu-tu-tu-tu-tu 28 minutes left a lot of
time let's go with them all right I
guess we're going with this I got to
watch out for that g4 pawn push
LightSquared Bishop Soph the board
looking for c5 my knight on f5 should be
good but let's get out of a pin first we
don't want to hang our queen do we let's
maybe that's a not a good idea for them
to be doing that pawn move
can I get in just be six and two take
care first and now I'm on that pond and
a a the a pond could be a problem to be
six and c5 maybe even f6 it's still put
pressure on that and maybe stop the King
from castling Queen to a6 or b5 or let's
take this guy if Bishop and I could take
the night with checker just take the
Queen I'm on the rook and the pond let's
take the pond and let's run away a
little bit and finally get castled
finally get Castle here before it's
maybe too late and what next
okay let's get this in here and I want
my knight on f6 that's why I'm doing
this
and they're not they're not allowing
that I shouldn't I should have taken
that a pond to 30 30 seconds okay let's
chop that and let's get my queen over
here guarding some stuff oh wait I
missed that move oh man
okay I need my knight to defend I think
defend night that could take their night
I'm gonna run away let's run away a
little bit push my pond it's in seconds
I guess I can't fall into one move mate
I think I should be alright if I don't
lose in the mate and 100 I have a flight
square for my king right that's a queen
trade Ron King you know you want to run
go remove remove remove I lose my rook
but they don't have any time back to
turn six six six five - ah here we go
who's this no alright efore we know our
okay and I'm liking this variation I
think know what f6 gonna be played no
okay you get my knight back to c3 let's
get back to c3 Bishop to D what no not
d3 okay that's coming under fire isn't
it and now let's come here this is
protected indirectly and dark squared
bishop sigh might want to put a question
to it Knight II let's see if they take
night here and maybe the Queen's gonna
be trapped
Knight to c5 next I guess they were
fearful of okay now the queen is gonna
be hit this is not yet an issue night
here I should have done Knight right
there let's get this I want knight on c5
hitting east six and now I'm hitting the
bishop how do I recapture let's go with
the rook I want to get to c7 I think
that would be a great thing let's not do
that so fast maybe e5 I want to focus on
that's coming all the way back Bishop my
dark square Bishop I got to get it doing
something that's my advantage but so
much for the dark square bishop let's
still focus on this I'm looking for
good versus bad bishop situations let's
let's get this guy out of there and then
pivot my knight on e5 now with tempo and
where's that um where does that rip
going let's come here I'm gonna take
that knife at a place to have five I'm
assuming that's going to rook to c7 is
available maybe let's not even allow the
night there my queen is here to watch
over I don't think it's gonna be that
much of an issue bumping my king up
looking for the H file now even might
have some stuff against this because
what's that Bishop doing on c8 it's kind
of dead offer of a queen exchange um do
I want that what do I do
I only oh I don't have any time I don't
have any time why did I spend so much
time on that I got a pre move let's
throw a check-in and then just come back
another one rook trade
I got a pre move like a maniac here I
gotta take that now they're not let me
take that I could have taken that pon
let's come back let's take this guy and
come back here this is a fantastic
commentary isn't it let's take that guy
and come back here yeah I would have
done that yeah I would have done that
let's take care they'll never suspect it
you see you got to do things that they
don't expect I got it okay sixteen
twelve twelve twelve I can't I don't
even have the time to look at the names
here we go mister unstoppable let's see
if he is unstoppable
if he wins he's unstoppable Bishop e7
okay let's back up I think we've been
here before myself in the unstoppable
one okay hang on a second let's put
pressure on that epon okay now
weaknesses Oh weaknesses let's push this
Knight around maybe a little bit let's
put pressure on this guy and now I'm
getting ready to win upon maybe let's
let's kick that away and can I get some
weaknesses here in this endgame is
everything gonna be alright I get the I
get a fork oh oh I think no that's
that's a good move wait let's take with
the bishop that was that was pretty
smooth right there
let's start this check-in or maybe not
hang on well yeah no no let's do this
the Knights in a pan wait this is
winning or is it what am I missing
I think I got it I think I got it I
think I got it I think I can I think I
can 24 seconds oh man um is this leading
to me let's watch over my knight I
should have done that with oh they
reside back to tournament unstoppable
one was stopped for just a second right
there I'll take it
21 seconds 20 20 20 18 16 okay oh here
comes another big dog it doesn't end it
does not end right here and I have to go
with this solid setup especially in
these Bullock games frame with that stop
their plan of b5 and let's maybe get an
e for with temp I also want to preserve
what what do I want to preserve my darks
cribbage if I was going to be playing h3
and let's change the structure see what
they want to do let's clamp down in that
pond and maybe still look to get in this
move and okay now I got to watch over
that and then come back here to watch
over Queen b3 stuff I want my knight on
c4 let's come here and flight square and
I'm in trouble it's coming right here oh
let's take him out I think II 5 to that
square would have been better and maybe
c4 is a problem mmm I want I like my
knight too much and I need to watch over
this pun let's play here Knight D okay I
think things are good oh they stopped my
plan let's get this guy involved and
maybe e5 at some point okay I need more
support over here more support let's
weaken the light squares get to g4 f5
I'm looking for f5 can I get that in
okay bad things are about to happen here
or maybe not
okay let's hit this pawn and then am I
getting this okay I'm gonna have to go
for it ugly and balanced but the seventh
rank seven
Frank and I get this I think I got it
maybe is this working out seven the two
pigs look at the two wild pigs on the
seventh let me get the Queen do I have
this look in the king as a flight square
I got this too they can't take there's
got to be mate here there I got time
time time time are they gonna resign I
just got to move quick hey night oh this
guy's going very quick let's get this
guy and then pre move here and then take
this with check or not
Oh get back here I don't have any time a
stepladder do I have enough time mate
let's hold on my breath on that when I
got it thirty seven thirty thirty whoo
oh I'm losing my breath right here let's
do it again let's try this instead are
they gonna play Smith more I gotta wait
I'll wait it out are they gonna move an
on mover I could use a breather I can
really move okay so this is Jed's well
how did this get to be a caro-kann okay
anyhow we're playing Carrick on
territory right now it's weasel this
night around a c4 and I'm looking for
this yeah yeah c4 definitely now give me
the c4 SquareTrade LightSquared bishop
so I would love it let's trade those
LightSquared bishop s' let's sort of
come back here for a second because I
realized my nighttime v6 he's he's gonna
want to have a more support but my
knight on c6 also wants some support if
a for this drops that pun so looking for
c4 now and it's coming with tempo here
we go here we go I got something good
Bruin Knight c4 and I have a time
advantage 94 now this is where I want to
be and I'm gonna take away from the
center so I have this square available
for my light square bishop and my queen
and even my knight let's get here quick
clean up a bishop back trade
dark-squared bishop smae B I'd love to
get that night out there actually f6 is
probably pretty good f6 coming up
opening up the F file it would subject
my epon to maybe some issues 15 seconds
for my opponent let's go with it I'm in
a spot to recapture with my queen and
maybe break down this structure let's
get my dark square Bishop doing
something and I might want to think
about taking with my pawn here or let's
watch out for this square actually and
that's that's a strong move
I shouldn't allowed that night to get
there but a mate maybe actually Brooke
takes bishop like Aronian Gary or Gary
Aronian but okay no time left forty to
fifty one forty seven forty to forty two
what do we got oh this guy who is he
twenty-two twenty-two hundred gotta get
the Queen okay get the Queen real quick
maybe I'm okay no let's go with this so
I have the oh okay let's do this I might
have to come all the way back home if
the pawn takes okay I'll watch over that
Bishop here and offer Queen exchange
give me the a file please I love the
Queen the Queen I are the the rook to
have the a file but maybe I want to come
back over here though because their King
is more vulnerable get that dark square
Bishop that's my number one priority get
that dark square Bishop off of there g2
is maybe an issue
let's get that Queen out of there and
come over here and I'm probably doing g3
soon let's do it now and let's get this
up Knight e5 this has to be take and I
think okay this is this is pretty good
for my opponent oh I should've a lot o
let's just all right I'm gonna trade a
bunch I think I still do better bishop
and in in this ensuing endgame
let's get them my rook over in this
direction and actually on second thought
let's come back over here looking for h4
it's still a fridge for an hour never
moment passed palm connected pass pawn
or not okay let's come back over here
I'm looking for this why'd they do that
oh that's why they did that okay
pretty slick right there crap what I do
broke up I almost messed that one up
right there oh man I gotta come back
here this is not good I have to crawl a
crunch couch up in a ball here
ah man not cool I mean check I'm getting
kicked around quite a bit this is not
good I have a poor King position I have
to get rid of that Bishop I think and I
could get that pun how much I only have
Oh
come on move over can I get much can I
sneak my king over I got to get here I
don't have any time though I have
absolutely no time no time whatsoever I
can't I can't even move my pawn okay now
I could maybe that's a good move I
couldn't do anything about I don't have
any time
oh I lost no hope no hope stalemate
stalemate it's not happening I lost back
to tournament oh that's a tough one to
stomach right there 67-63 here we go
another turn or another tournament okay
let's remain calm here all right I have
to go into crazy mode here and caro-kann
isn't that crazy mode oh okay
I had so little time on that man 43
seconds right now okay the queen is
maybe could be hit let's come over here
Knight here okay my this is this is an
issue now the knight has to move or
something my Knights to be taken its hit
the Queen and maybe take here depending
on where the Queen goes and this is
gonna be great now hitting everything
everything this is gonna be a fork to
rooks and what else there's Queen here I
could maintain that fork for a little
bit I have a lot of coordination between
our pieces Queen c7
more exchanges coming up are they gonna
resign they're gonna let your clock tick
what is going on with that I'm gonna
take that and I would take that
what's going on with these fools why has
my opponent doing this to me they're
just burning time let's come back Rupp
takes night-night here no the Bishop's
on it forget about that let's do this
I'm not falling into one move mate am I
um let's just do that
gotta watch out for this it's my only
concern what is going on what is this
guy doing three seconds two I'm just
gonna do that for fun burn the time
time's up back to tournament 8167 56 54
52 here we go nine home the night can't
go there and then I can't go here either
what's going on with my mouse back to
tournament yes they got they were fear
in my mouse on that one
81 72 70 okay let's go here 12 minutes
left
Wow here we go I'm playing against jazzy
87 20 76 let's do this instead I tricked
them no caro-kann whoa let's not go to
b6 either Knight g4 pick up the dark
square Bishop and now we'll go here and
pinpoint that and I'm gonna take that
cuz that's a free pun and my queen is
dead and are very close to it oh she's
gotta run home I need a flight square
for my queen run Queen she's got a run I
was gonna play h5 I think she's safe for
a second no not quite
wait she could come here oh wait a
second this is scary
oh man oh man oh I think 95 would have
been good okay she's been rescued wow
did that take a while
rescued that clean
and okay let's get castled and then get
this night out doing something exciting
isn't gonna take my LightSquared bishop
there we go now things are coming
together
let's kick them around let's see how
they like it okay let's back up let's
get my rook whoa are they gonna give me
their LightSquared bishop i need to gain
some time here light square bishop whoa
east seven as well I got to get out of
that I can't think I just got to move f7
is hit my queen is gonna start getting
harassed again just like that just go
here even if it's wrong they'll just go
15 seconds it's not turning out pretty
what's going on they're not taking that
I got a pre move take the Queens oh I
could have taken the Brooke I'm gonna
take this they'll never suspect it and
AH they shouldn't have done that
oh they got my Dykstra Bishop and I'm in
a pin I'm gonna pin them back oh man
uh-oh I got a run over here right there
let's get this in I think it was their
pawn lose their fun give a check Oh No
let's give a check I have no time I
mated
oh man that took the wind right out of
me
that one was hurt that was hurting me
right there ah 68 I need to get top
three come on I want a granola bar I
want some crowns in other words I should
have been able to get that one why
didn't I win that one
it's just not happening it's not
happening I should have had that one
though my queen you know I probably
wasted a ton of time reacting to how
those Queen threats that's where all my
time win
and there goes another pun okay I want
to hang on to what Bishop okay they're
not taking either one let's break down
this I want to get at g7 and let's so
the light squares as well how about okay
definitely in this direction is good I
think
mm how about this okay let's get over
here I'm gonna be sneaky Oh why'd I go
there
mm let's pin that night and then chase
this one away uh-oh okay let's get that
in and okay now know what's going on
here what's the story so many tell me
the story here I got to get my king
closer in this direction and pile up on
what and I want to pile up on I want to
open up the position still oh and that's
not the way to do it okay let's try this
and hit this night and then just take
that pun and play here okay and now this
is a nasty pin whoa on that night and
check and then let's take here and then
take this pawn I pay let's see um let's
see the Primo skill push the pun they'll
never suspect that I got this guy going
now
let's throw some checks in
trip them I tricked them I want to get
some more checks let's check let's check
again let's come over here yes back to
tournament everybody knows that rook
versus King beats a queen versus King
right
Oh quick resign I need some quick resign
errs here I need to throw my age pond
down to somehow get this win
d5 okay let's get Bishop to g4 you're
gonna take and then work themselves into
a pin same thing maybe pressure md4 if
that happens okay let's take this
centers close I'm not sure if the dark
if the bishops are that valuable now
uh-oh mm get rid of that dark square
bishop mmm
or actually yeah I should have done that
maybe f5 I think I need to do f5 before
it's too late they're breaking down my
LightSquared structure and I like that
they're kind of tied down to the defense
of their dark square bishop bishop here
can maybe be pretty good hit that rook
and lend support oh why are they giving
you that now let's take this and then
this and then I'm looking for rook f3
next they're defending against that I
might need to do this pawn move okay
this this trade is good for me isn't it
get my king over here let's support this
I want to get that move in and now let's
get over here 26 seconds to work this
one out oh oh man oh man what am i doing
let's get my king over here why did I do
that okay I'm not gonna be winning or
maybe I am oh now I am they were trying
to be sneaky with that move push this
and then get up here throwing some
checks here pick up some time and let's
let's throw another check-in in another
and then take here this is a one king
upon end game
okay back to tournament what do I got
129 126 123 108 five minutes left
quick resign oh I want in the e4 we're
gonna take on that square okay let's
let's throw this guy down here let's see
what they do okay let's get a floor in
maybe let's go with it already capture
with my queen and then play what is that
they drop that pun I'm smashing this
open now queenside castle Oh are they
gonna resign I'm on everything here
oh there's take right here leading to me
yes quick they're not gonna resign come
on let's go they're not resigning oh man
what do you got I have to prove there we
go back to tournament third so far
156 129 126 4 minutes left here we go c5
knight c6 okay close Sicilian and are
they gonna take like that okay I guess
so and I don't want my knight right over
here for a queen exchange if the Queen
plays there this is a strong move I
think I have to put pressure on that pun
and force it into a decision and let's
get my knight over here to defend some
key squares I think the g5 one in
particular and now this Knight is um
hanging maybe Knight takes Knight I get
this night and I takes Knight Queen
takes also Bishop to g4 maybe 37 seconds
I have a time advantage of also on c2
also on c2 Knight takes Knight okay I
got this Knight right
if the Queen blocks will take the Queen
and then take the knight back to
tournament 146 156 146 128
three minutes three minutes okay this is
the guy that I ended up having that
queen sack against I think oh they
disconnected 56 seconds 55 53 52 51 how
much time is left three minutes okay so
wait this is how it's gonna work out I
think if unless this guy comes back I'm
gonna get this win and then I'll have
one more game I'll have one more game in
just enough time I believe because
there's two minutes 56 seconds there's
33 seconds before this game is finished
okay let's see how it finishes 156 146
128 127 these guys could definitely
catch me maybe I could catch one 56 17
seconds here we go this is gonna be
tight this is gonna be real tight I had
a couple losses even there's there's
tournaments want to win all the games
and then I still don't even I'm still
not even up there how am i up top with
having losses here we go
games over and back to tournament 156 I
have a two two point lead two minutes
left to 15 the clock is ticking oh let's
go I could get one more win in is this
gonna work out come on I need to get
this win oh my bishops trapped okay
that's alright let's all right stay calm
stay calm here here we go come on you
could fight back you could do this you
like how I'm uh giving myself a little
pep talk okay
man why did I drop that piece so quick
why did I drop it so quick now this and
this they might fall for it they might
give a bishop check and it's a losing
move okay let's do this because I could
take night and I take c6 I'm on either
dark square Bishop let's pin there
Knight my knight I know five is strong
and oh they could have taken my bishop
that's good oh I should have kept my
rook over here okay rook up and over
rook up and then over
let's get rid of their darks for a
bishop maybe with check and play here
pins Queen III rip to it rip to e3
there's a fork and stuff but I think I
want look here I'm on the night let's
get this in what do I want what I want
I'm on the knight twice am I missing
something I gotta get this win I got it
I got a sack my queen and I get can I
get there Knight can I get a fork
they're gonna give me that mmm take this
take that pawn I'm on the night I'm
getting am I getting mated though what
are they what do they get what do they
get what do they got nothing like it no
no that's not a good pre move 14 seconds
okay I could pre move a lot here I think
and yes they drop their queen I'm gonna
take it back to term at 176 170 for 15
seconds 14 13 Oh first place why do they
cut it short what's going on there first
place there was 15 seconds left and then
they just are like no they're like no
this match could not go on here and it
was against Casey Kings crusher it
didn't even start though I could have
sworn it said 15 seconds and then it was
like oh I don't know how to explain it
it's I could have sworn it said 15
seconds this game popped up and they're
like somebody blew a whistle at chess
cube and they're like this game cannot
happen man let me go back Wow
good games oh that was absolutely nuts
and I got some granola bars out of it
too 40 crowns that is four granola bars